so let's talk a little bit about groups
of the periodic table now in a very
simple way to think about groups is that
they just are the columns of the
periodic table and a standard convention
is to number them this is the first
column so that's Group one second column
third group fourth fifth sixth seventh
eighth nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 and
18 and I know some of you all might be
thinking what about these F block
elements over here if we were to
properly do the periodic table we would
shift all of these they're everything
from the D block and P block all right
words and make room for these F block
elements but the convention is is that
we don't number them but what's
interesting why do we go through the
trouble about calling one of these
columns but calling these columns a
group well this is what's interesting
about the periodic table is that all of
the elements in a column for the most
part and there's tons of exceptions but
for the most part the elements in the
column have very very very similar
properties and that's because the
elements in a column or the elements in
a group tend to have the same number of
electrons in their outermost shell they
tend to have the same number of valence
electrons and valence electrons and
electrons in the outermost shell they
tend to coincide although there's a
slightly different variation the valence
electrons these are the react the
electrons that are going to react while
the which tend to be the outermost shell
electrons but there are there are
exceptions to that and actually there's
actually a lot of interesting exceptions
that happen in the transition metals in
the d-block but we're not going to go
into those details let's just think a
little bit about some of the the groups
that you will hear about and and why
they react in very similar ways so if we
go at Group 1 group 1 and hydrogen is a
little bit of a of a strange character
because hydrogen isn't trying to get to
eight valence electrons hydrogen in that
first shell just wants to get to two
valence electrons like helium has and so
hydrogen is is kind of it's it's not
it's not it doesn't share as much in
common with everything else in Group one
as you might expect for say all of the
things in
in group 2 group 1 if you put hydrogen
aside these are referred to as the
alkali metals and hydrogen is not
considered an alkali metal so these
right over here are the alkali alkali
metals now why do all of these have very
similar reactions why do they have very
similar properties well to think about
that you have to think about their
electron configurations so for example
the electron configuration for lithium
is going to be the same as the electron
configuration of the of helium of helium
and then you're going to go to your
second shell 2s 1 it has 1 valence
electron it has 1 electron in its outer
in its outermost shell
what about sodium well
sodium is going to have the same
electron configuration as neon and then
it's going to go 3 s 1 so once again it
has one valence electron one electron in
its outermost shell so all of these
elements in orange right over here they
have one valence electron and they're
trying to get to the octet rule this
kind of stable nirvana for 4 atoms and
so you could imagine is that they're
very reactive and when they react they
tend to lose this electron in their
outermost shell and that is the case
these alkali metals are very very
reactive and actually they have very
similar properties they're shiny and
soft and actually they're because
they're so reactive it's hard to find
them where they haven't reacted with
other things well let's keep looking at
the other groups well if we move one
over to the right this group to right
over here these are called the alkaline
earth metals alkaline alkaline earth
metals and once again they have very
similar they have very similar
properties and that's because they have
two valence electrons two electrons in
their outermost shell and also for them
not as quite as reactive as the alkali
metals but let me write this
alkaline earth metals but for them it's
easier to lose two electrons than to try
to gain six to get to eight and so these
tend to also be reasonably reactive and
they react by losing those two outer
electrons now something hat interesting
happens as you go to the d-block
and we studied this when we looked at
electron configurations but if you look
at the electron configuration for say
scandium right over here the electron
let me do it in magenta the electron
configuration for scandium so scandium
scan diems electron configuration is
going to be the same as argon it's going
to be argon the Aufbau principle would
tell us that the electron configuration
we would have the 4s - just like calcium
but by the Aufbau principle we would
also have one electron in 3d so it would
be argon then 3d one for s2 and to get
things in the right order for our shells
let me put the 3d one before the 4s -
and so when people think about the
Aufbau principle they imagine all of
these d-block elements as somehow
filling the d-block now as we know in
other videos that's not exactly true but
when you're conceptualizing the electron
configuration it might be useful then
you come over here and you start filling
the p-block
so for example if you look at the
electron configuration for let's say
carbon carbon is going to have the same
electron configuration as helium as
helium and then you're going to fill
your s block to s 2 and then to p1 - so
- p2 so how many valence electrons does
it have well in its second shell its
outermost shell has two plus two and has
four valence electrons and that's going
to be true for the things in this group
and because of that carbon has similar
bonding behavior to silicon - the other
things in its group and we can keep
going on
you know for example oxygen and oxygen
and sulfur these would both want to take
two electrons from someone else because
they have six valence electrons they
want to get to eight so they have
similar bonding behavior you go to this
yellow group right over here these are
the halogens so there's a special name
for them these are the halogens and
these are highly reactive because they
have seven valence electrons they would
love nothing more than to get one more
valence electron so they love to react
in fact they especially love to react
with the alkali metals over here and
then finally you get to kind of your
atomic Nirvana in the noble gases here
and so the noble gas is that's the other
name for the group 18 elements noble
gases and they all have the very similar
property of not being reactive
why don't they react they have filled or
their outermost shell they don't find
the need they're noble they're kind of
above the fray they don't they they
don't find the need to have to react
with anyone else